they're the latest in wearable gadgets
for the way we live and play and the way
we work all supported by advances in the
virtual ways we interact with our world
oh my God okay there's a woman here I
feel rather embarrassed okay that's
rather disturbing
and then some devices that leave you
wondering whether humanity is the winner
or loser so you can check 100 workers to
make sure they're all concentrated and
if someone's not concentrating what
happens to them then
Japan once blazed the trail as the
world's Pioneer in the personal Gadget
oh wait yes there is but it now lags
behind its rivals in finding innovative
ways to use its high-tech skills I'm
using uh this kind of smart glasses for
more than 20 years in the west
especially the United States there is
more of a mood of innovation Japanese
consumers are not as excited about this
technology it's hoped big events like
this scaled back during the pandemic
will now help Japan restore what it sees
as its rightful position as the leading
provider of the latest and niftiest
must-have I think we're getting a lot of
people coming today and uh it seems like
we're back to like 2018 with Mars but
with masses just have a virtual mask
Wonder yes hopefully
many devices Now find a natural role
post pandemic as we become more
contactless but all of them it seems
more complex
one of the new areas of innovation is
so-called energy harvesting whereby
gadgets of the future will be powered by
your own body heat so even if you don't
understand them simply wearing them will
be doing some good
adorning ourselves with Evermore gadgets
but still a little room for the part
that's human Rob McBride Al Jazeera
Tokyo